الفرق مع أصدقائي انتهى
هداف من نهائي كورونا ماترا
djet عقد على أرض أوروبا 3.8 و
أتهم
عرض ساروف يقول إنها ليست على مستوى ذلك
لي الحسن مبري اختار جوجل
تشارلز فري مثل الذهاب بعيدا جدا
9 5 مع شيلي وجورجيا حيث لا شيء
الحرية لا توجد دون الحاجة إلى الحرية
حيث لا أدين بشيء لعدم وجود أحد
لا ، إنه خيال
يسأل الناس أنفسهم أماه
الحرية تنتهي فقط حيث الحرية
من ناحية أخرى تبدأ لكنها قبل كل شيء
يقوم على الشعور بالواجب المتبادل
ما هي قيمة حريتك إذا أخبرتني
لا أريد أن أتلقى التطعيم
ولكن إذا قمت غدًا بتلويث
والد أمك أو أنا أنا
ضحية حريتك وأنت
أتيحت له الفرصة للحصول على شيء
شيء لحمايتك ولي
وباسم حريتك بعد غد
ربما كنت تسير قبل الشكل
جاد ستصل إلى هذا المستشفى
كل هؤلاء الأفراد هم من يذهبون
يجب أن تعتني بك و
ربما سيتعين عليهم الاستسلام
تأخذ برامج شخص آخر
وعملية باسم حريتك
هذه ليست حرية تسمى
يتم استدعاء المسؤوليات هناك
أنانية المجتمع فقط عندما
حرية كل واحترام
الآخر وبالتالي فهو يقوم على
الحقوق و الواجبات
أكثر أكثر يوما بعد يوم غالب دالغلب